jamal adams wanted out of new york and
he got his wish the mega trade to the
seahawks two first round picks
a third round pick safety bradley
macdougall for jamal adams and a fourth
round pick in 2022. rodney harrison your
thoughts on the decision to send
arguably the best safety in the nfl to
seattle for all of that compensation i
didn't like it mike um i look at the gym
they draft fix brawl
as a foundation player as a leader on
that defense and
you know he becomes a pro bowl player
all pro player he exceeded expectations
he becomes the best safety international
football league but yet the jets don't
want to pay him and jamal is a very
passionate guy he's very he's so much
he's very similar to me and he wears all
his emotions on his sleeves and yes he
could have handled the situation a lot
better understand that this is business
and he talked himself out of of new york
but i mean i think he's a tremendous
player and the jets i think they made a
mistake he's a hall of fame talent you
don't let guys like that walk out the
door and just my last point i want to
make on this you go pay a guy like cj
mosley from the baltimore ravens that
you didn't drive he wasn't in your
system but you pay him 40 50 million
dollars you go out and get le'veon bell
and jamal adams is your best player on
your team you got a quarterback playing
off a rookie deal but yet you don't want
to make him the highest paid safety in
the national football league the jets
blew it i just think they made a huge
mistake here well i i listen i i agree
with everything you said about the
player i mean you're right he's a hall
of fame talent to me he is the best
safety in football i mean i think you
probably argue during when james is in
that combo too i think but yeah but but
so
but what were the jets supposed to do i
mean don't you think they kind of had to
make a trade happen with the way jamal
was talking and things like that i mean
i understood but
the way he was talking is because he's
upset when you give everything to an
organization when you give everything to
a team the fan base you expect to be
rewarded you're putting your life on the
line you see what that guy brings every
single day the intensity it didn't
matter what the record was it didn't
matter what situation the jets were and
he always came to play he was always a
productive player and yeah i would get
pissed off too if i have to sit on a
garbage team and they don't even want to
pay me when i'm out there i'm a top five
or six defensive player i'm the best
safety international football league but
yet you don't want to pay me i think
it's crazy and i also think it sends a
message to everybody else across the
league why would i want to come and play
for the jets if they can't even play
jamal paid jamal adams who's the best
safety international football league i
think it's i think it's terrible yeah
well i hear that but yeah hang on yeah
rodney there's a difference though right
i don't remember young rodney harrison
going and this is before jamal adams got
upset with adam gase and got upset with
his contract back in 2018 his second
season todd bowles the coach of the team
at the time was constantly having to
clean up messes made by jamal adams he
would call out teammates he said on
radio in 2018 everybody was used to
losing he was talking about the jets you
could always tell that vibe i came in it
was like everybody wanted to do the bare
minimum they didn't want to go above and
beyond they didn't want to take the
extra step i don't remember young rodney
harrison calling teammates out like that
publicly that was the first sign that
this thing was destined for trouble
between atoms and the jets well it's
it's it's your you know some people
maybe you look at is calling the guys
out
maybe he looks at it as holding them
accountable because i mean when you come
in and you're getting there at 5 30 6
o'clock in the morning you're lifting
weights you're doing everything right
you're productive you see other guys
messing around not as focused and you
expect your coaches to try to get those
guys in order and if those guys aren't
in order yeah what are you supposed to
do yeah you can pull them to the side
and you can talk to them but sometimes
you have to call people out sometimes
you have to go up to a guy and say hey
man you know you're not getting it done
we need you to be a lot better but yeah
jamal could have handled the situation a
lot better he could have been more um uh
professional he could have been more
sincere you know he didn't have to do
some of the things and i'm sure he would
tell you once he sits down that yeah
he's made some mistakes and he feels bad
about it but ultimately he got his wish
he did what he had to do to get up out
of there all right so you gotta just at
least hit on what do you think it means
to seattle now that they got the best
safety in football in this hall of fame
type talent what do you think it does to
their defense and their team rodney i
think it's terrific i mean they lose a
guy like davey and clowney and i think
you know when you lose a guy like davian
clowney a guy that can get after the
quarterback and he's been hurt and you
know he's off and on but you get that
stabilizer and jamal adams that guy
that's gonna
team up with quadray digs and be that
physical presence and really bring that
electricity every single week you see
the division that they're in with all
those really good quarterbacks so i
think it's huge for seattle
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports